If you said four batches, way to go. I know for the first fourth cup of sugar,
I'll make one batch of brownies. For the next fourth cup of sugar, I'll make
another batch of brownies. Another fourth cup of sugar will give me another
batch of brownies, and my last fourth cup of sugar will give me another batch of
brownies. I started with one cup of sugar and I wanted to see how many times did
1/4 divide into one cup. I can turn division into multiplication by multiplying
by the reciprocal. So, 1 times 4 over 1. I get 1 times 4, which is 4, and 1
times 1, which is 1. 4 divided by 1, makes 4. The key idea in all these problems
is that dividing by a fraction is the same as multiplying by the reciprocal of
the fraction. We're going to use this idea in the next problem.